I learned this thing recently that you
know the Philippines doesn't have has
never had like any serial killers
that's so hard to believe that is hard I
mean there's obviously like very like
[__] up Mass killing of certain things
by the government by the government well
you shoot me a video once oh God all
right what did I show you this was
insane there was a family right who one
of the families was a cop
and the other family and the guy just
went to the neighbor's house and shocked
the grandmother yeah that's a murderer
that's not a serial killer someone who
goes around for months at a time and you
know someone who's trying to like leave
you so human but you know why
so no but there's a very specific reason
why humidity no because we have
I just it's hard to hysterical when it's
that hot no we have like the chismosa
culture so apparently our gossip culture
and the speed at which gossip goes
around between like titas and families
prevents like like if there's someone
that's a murderer you'll know about it
like the next day
they say gossip's not good but is it
look Oh see it's a culture chismosa
culture wow so gossip is good yeah so I
was saying you know how your mouth is
you just run your mouth yeah it's not a
bad thing you could be saving lives yeah
but I lie a lot oh yeah that's true
that's a problem yeah I mean I lie a lot
countries with the most serial killers
obviously United States wait who's that
number ones in the United States
obviously number two is what England
makes sense yeah look at the number
between us and everyone else it's like
staggering it's so staggering and it's
not because we're the biggest ones Spain
17 Andres let's go to the end who's like
the Netherlands has had 12 in their
history that's crazy that's crazy I do
Wonder though how accurate this is
because what about like you know like
the police and like you know what do we
like what would we do in the Philippines
how do we keep track of they don't
serial killers yeah they have a sense of
consent but I do believe there is
something about how gossipy like the
titas are back home where I don't think
anyone can get past like maybe one or
two killings do you know what I mean out
of all the people we've had on the
podcast
who do you think would be the one that
we were gossiping about that could be a
Sarah color oh [__] run some names let's
go through okay we'll start with an easy
one person let me just name some names
I'll say some we'll start with Rick
Glassman just put it out there no way no
way yes yes absolutely yes yes what's
your case for yes
I don't know I don't have a case I just
because he was telling me that I want to
kill people no no he wasn't that he
called me up one day hey do you have 800
Grand and I go
I go why he goes there's a there's a a
card I want to get magic a magic card oh
my God okay in the east coast and in my
head I'm like this guy could kill
somebody that's all because
he's like a good investor no 800 000 to
buy a magic card yeah is is insane
Behavior first of all the phone call
just to call me on not Hello someone
else let's do another yeah let's do
let's go through the first okay first
name okay here I think that he has a
perfect look for it but I don't think I
think he has too much Integrity but a
great serial killer look is Sam Morel oh
the vibe yeah he's got yeah to me he's
more um Oklahoma City Bombing like in
like really intellectual yeah he's more
like one time one shot you know what I
mean 300 kill seriously kind of a guy
when you look at like come on yeah for
sure like first great face yeah yeah
great Facebook yeah
all right so Sam Morel maybe let's we're
gonna go one through ten to see if 10 is
the serial killer and yeah all right
let's just start with just random names
okay Eddie Wong
Eddie Wong I can see a Virginia Tech
it's Asia that's a racist way I can see
a Virginia Tech on that I don't see it I
rate him like maybe uh serial killer
potential like a 1.5 whoa very low Judd
Apatow
all is zero he is a wholesome Daddy yeah
wholesome Daddy good very good that's
what I wanted yeah so thanks Judd
[Laughter]
um David Spade
David Spade uh what do you think
it'd be there be a ten or a one yeah
exactly yes one or the other you could
get away with it because he has like the
nice uh the nice face looking he gets
away with a lot yeah it's just like when
my my best friend when we were younger
she was like really like innocent
looking Asian girl so we would have we
would send her to steal all of the stuff
from Sephora that we wanted because no
one ever suspected her because she was
just so like cute and like innocent
looking okay okay so he's kind of that
right I'm gonna throw out a name okay A
little controversial he's been on a
podcast schaab
no zero no zero zero two yeah because
he's he's uh I you'd see him coming yeah
I think yeah yeah yeah I think he would
leave a lot of track and he also doesn't
know how red it works
I'm being serious you have to know how
to do computer stuff
keep that head you're right you're right
is that crazy what I just said no no
you're right he doesn't know how red it
works yeah yeah
is this our last episode
let's move on really quick I'd like to
present you guys with a gift actually
okay
um I don't know if you guys are familiar
with this there's a very popular uh
Instagram
um what do you call it like yeah
Instagram page called celebs on
sandwiches so during the pandemic this
guy blew up because you can't commission
from him but he will just chew